okay uh we received a question so this
is our next Gateway video it's a common
expression uh repeated and attributed to
osensei uh it doesn't matter that this
is not the exact quote but this is how
it was phrased in the question okay
and uh the phrase attributed to O Sensei
is something akin to everything in
Aikido is an EQ okay ikyo on Japanese
means first teaching okay so the phrase
is uh they're everything you could ever
want is in the first teaching uh the
first teaching is important everything's
in there any of those variations okay
and we're asked here for this Gateway
video is this true but really do I agree
with that okay and I would say yes
but we have to remember some things okay
Ikea is part of kihon Maza
are not self-defense responses
are in essence purification rituals okay
so we have to understand what's going on
here
Silk Road culture
which eventually leads us
from Mainland Asia and eventually into
Japan
had something
um
I don't want to say unique but it it
compared to Modern understanding it's
different I mean it's hard hard for us
to understand okay
so let's say you have spiritual
Traditions that really focus in
on uh let's say the mind or the soul or
the spirit
um
and then you have other spiritual
traditions that will
allow for some sort of energetic
investigation into things okay so for
example
um I would say modern day Buddhism
is very much almost like a psychology
nowadays so it's almost irrelevant what
the body is doing okay the reason that's
possible is because in pre-modern
Buddhism that seed was planted okay it
degenerated into what we have today
which I would say is not even Buddhism
but the seed was there okay that you
could look at the mind
without an energetic component or
without a body component although
pre-modern times they never did really
okay they never did when you get deeper
into it you look at what they're
actually doing
they didn't really but there was room
for it hence what we have today
if we take another tradition such as
Taoism
it's it's impossible it's it's
more impossible to look at taoism as
only a kind of philosophy and of the
mind it's just there's too much history
and too much obviousness to deny that
there is a body component and more
importantly there's an energetic
component and so you have to deal with
those things okay Aikido
on that Silk Road at the end of that
Silk Road adopted
that idea of its human cultivation you
going to work at those three levels of
physical level an energetic level and
then what I am calling uh so that
moderns understand more easily is a
spiritual level okay
um okay so I have these three levels
it's not just a mind it's not just a
psychology uh it's got to have this
energetic value
okay that's key
and it has a body component so let's
just take this one and what are you
trying to do in this tradition
well it's holding that
there was a Dao the Dow split and
manifested yin and yang and from yin and
yang the rest of the world was created
the rest of the cosmos was created
well this is a kind of uh
it's hard to say is it doulas is it
monus it's both okay because you can't
reverse it so when I lose the
distinction between yin and yang I get
back to the nameless okay so what you're
trying to do in Aikido
is in my verbiage
transcend yin and Young
you're trying to do that energetically
when you energetically transcend yin and
yang
physically
you'll generate a non-contesting
marshall tactical application
you will also generate an IQ adhesion
here because two things will become one
and at a spiritual level the two minds
will also be reconciled so just like
there's two things and they're going to
become one thing the two minds will
become one thing too okay
meaning if I can generate
a Reconciliation again and yang I'm
going to have aiki at an energetic level
at the spiritual level my mind will
actually
organize itself
so to speak
in a way very much like a tradition
that's working just on the mind just on
the mind of Enlightenment gets to do
okay so you can in this tradition hey
you can develop that in lightly's mind
by working on yourself energetically
okay and so that that is what you're
trying to do now
how do you do that
well
you have this idea
that the way to reconcile yin and yawn
because it's often represented like this
if you spin these things
okay so for example let us just say that
this is Young
and this one is here
okay so the vertical line is Young and
the horizontal line is Yin well if I
rotate
the young Line is now horizontal making
it Yin so theoretically I transition
Yong to Yin you see that I made that and
now they just keep expanding this
concept and they go if I keep spinning
it see Yang keeps turning into Yin Yin
keeps turning into young they no longer
exist in this kind of polar opposition
to each other and I keep mixing it and
mixing it okay and as I mix them I
change their values ever they don't
maintain their oppositional
nature
they start to transcend because they
lose their dichotomous relationship to
each other so what Aikido does in this
simple understanding is it rotates them
both as I just did two dimensionally
this way
and also this way it rotates them and
then it takes that whole cross
and it is spinning it horizontally
vertically as it's moving it on a spiral
horizontally vertically okay and this is
going to reconcile yin and yang you're
going to get it you'll see an adhesion
as the ukes body and the naga's body
become one they get stuck together
physically stuck together
what you'll experience if you can do it
is you'll enter into that ecstatic State
you'll lose your subjective sense of
identity you'll reconcile fear you'll
reconcile your Will To Power and now you
could be described on one with the Dao I
am the Dow the Dow is emanating through
me okay that's what you're trying to do
this notion of taking the first of
something or the smallest of something
is a notion you see throughout mystical
traditions
Aikido is a mystical tradition because
this process of division into two things
back into one thing or the reconciling
of the two minds or the loss of the
subjective experience of self that is
the mystical experience okay
in mystical Traditions it is very very
common
to take the first of something or the
smallest of something to get
practitioners to realize don't focus on
the surface of things go to the heart of
the matter what is the heart of the
matter here is this reconciliation of
Yin and young energy within your body
internalize in the lower taunted field
that is where that happens okay that is
what you're supposed to do
so for example you have in the gospel of
Matthew Jesus will compare the Kingdom
of Heaven to a mustard seed the tiniest
of seeds throughout the mystical
discourses of history and culture you're
going to see of reference to the first
of something the smallest of something
to get practitioners to not get lost in
the weeds of the surface of things okay
so what this means then is
you're going to spiral rotate
your lower Tom Dan field to reconcile
yin and yang
in both directions you'll do it once to
the left and wants to the right so you
complete all the directions because
you're rotating vertically and
horizontally okay and that means there's
nothing else to do
that is all in ikyo but it does not mean
that you couldn't have said it's all a
Nico it's all the song kill it's in
everything that's in everything the
pointer here Ezekiel is you don't need
to look Beyond especially if you can't
understand this at the first teaching
level
okay so let me now show you
how you see both spiraling rotating
cross patterns one to the left one to
the right in equal if it is done
correctly okay you can't do any old
pattern you have to do the spiraling
rotating cross pattern of your lower top
10 field which requires that you're
moving a particular way you can't move
any old way okay
it also so happens that because it's a
concentric understanding
it also so happens if I generate the
proper energetic value the spiraling
rotating cross in both directions
you will also have a marshally viable EQ
when you see that this is doing yum yum
clashes or only rotating the tandem
field in One Direction not back in the
other direction you'll see that you
don't have a marshally viable EQ okay
so we'll show that now
okay so as an energetic purification
ritual why is this purification because
the manifestation of Yin and Yang is the
worldly manifestation it's the world
manifestation and the world is polluting
you see we are of the world we are of
matter but we are also not of matter if
we get too much worldly too much of
matter too materialistic like we are you
get polluted you
you aren't what you're supposed to be
okay what are you supposed to be you are
you are an embodied spirit
because that's what you are okay and
what happens as we become secular
materialists just look at the stats
you're gonna go crazy that's what's
gonna happen to you because that is not
what you are so in Christian or Catholic
discourse my own instead of saying
you're one with the Dao you would say
you're now an imager of God okay you God
works through you you're an imager of
God that is your true nature that is
what you're supposed to be you're not
supposed to be Cain in the city you were
supposed to be Adam in the Garden of
Eden okay
so I'm going to purify Myself by undoing
the things of the world and what the
world is in essence is the dichotomy
between yin and yang so the first thing
we do in the ritual is he's going to
press into me
I'm going to use that young energy I'm
gonna take it internally bounce it off
the ground so it's going to go down I'm
going to sink it down to the ground
young I'm going to convert it to Chi
it's uh to to uh Yin she I'm gonna
bounce it back up it's going to be
yamchi and then I'm going to start
rotating it in my taunted field okay so
as he pushes here uh it's not in my arm
it's
swelling and establishing that Tom Den
field
I feel the bouncing and now I'm going to
start rotating it so the field in this
case because you grab my right hand the
rotating cross is going to turn to the
right first before it comes to the left
so it goes to the right it doesn't
matter if you do it with Maneuvers does
not matter it goes to the right as it
goes to the right first it's going to go
up so watch his Center boom boom his
Center goes up because my pond end field
goes up so to the right up back to the
left and then it's going down now I've
done one side of the spiraling rotating
cross completing it here
come around Tamara
now I'm going to go the other way with
the spiraling rotating cross so it's
going to go to the left whoa comes
around it went up and then it goes down
home and this is where the technique
ends on the down so I've done both sides
of the spiraling rotating cross
foreign
[Music]
this is different
no rotation
very calm in this version
boom or this version that's
pushing straight in
pushing straight in brace
no let me have it
pulling out you're thinking you can go
here brace
no
doesn't work
rotate
Grace I'm not gonna go that way I go
this way
I'm not going to go this way I go that
way
my mind
you'll start to feel it if you can do it
you'll hit
that state of mind you want
all right let's try it
okay so the question that my Desi
brought up is uh they're getting pushed
over okay uh why is that happening
because she cannot internalize the young
energy if you cannot internalize the
young energy
you cannot generate the tonden field you
won't get the rebounding young energy
you won't be able to convert Yong to Yin
and then yin to Yang and then you won't
be able to rotate the tandoned field
because it doesn't exist and the 2G do
not exist either okay all that happens
is that the young energy is coming up
your arm and into wherever you Flex
usually the shoulder or the bicep area
okay so we'll and this was your question
so did you see how I explained it though
yes okay so you're gonna go
[Music]
yes and this is what's happening okay so
uh
you can you can stand up
okay and you can you can push push push
push push push Pusher push your freaking
hardest use use all of your strength
okay so it's not I'm not you can do that
but I want you to see
how it's okay you see so
again it's not that I'm bracing if you
pay attention you Flex in your brakes so
if I flex and Brace go ahead go ahead
and you can see okay so you have the
angle
you have you can probably generate more
young energy than I could when I tried
to go young so you're making me into you
you see that but
when I don't contest you remember at the
physical level I'm going to have
non-contestation
non-contestation by people who are
secular materialists
means you push me I get out of the way
non-contestation means your energy
passes through
okay that's what we want so you could
see as I started to get this bracing
can't and the flexion whoa you got me
okay so you're here
and you're pushing again and again uh it
doesn't matter
push it doesn't my posture is not
relevant to what I'm doing okay it does
it doesn't matter do you see so you're
pushing are you getting tired okay push
so
doesn't matter
what I'm doing because it's just passing
through me okay
um and you need to have that skill
in order to even start this process okay
okay so we're now we can answer this
more directly
everything in aikida is in Ikea is this
true okay energetically yes
it's true
in terms of purification misogi yes it's
true
in terms of generating the ecstatic or
mystical experience yes is true in terms
of doing what you're supposed to do as a
human being as a human organism return
to the Dao or become an imager of God
yes it's true
Marshall Lee no it's not true
okay remember
is this
it's a ritual exercise for this okay
in terms of otherwise is it true can
they be everything yes and no yes from
energetically misogi static experience
imager of God yes marshally no
you need you need more okay and that's
why we don't Define Aikido as is
kihonawaza there is much much more to
aikido especially marshally than it's
kihonawasa so this is my answer for this
last Gateway video thank you